pro sekunde ich höre gerade es gibt
tatsächlich breaking news aus berlin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in der spd-zentrale manchmal und herren
tut sich was und wie schaltet man direkt
rüber vor das willy-brandt-haus zu
carolin kebekus caro ist die spd jetzt
doch wieder bereit für die groko nein
eben nicht das zieht sich alles noch
ewig hin bei den sitzen pro jahr
nein vielleicht und der kanzlerin reicht
das jetzt angela merkel hat es im guten
versucht aber wenn die genossen partout
nicht in die regierung wollen dann zieht
sie jetzt eben andere saiten auf die
andere seite
da ist wohl heute eine art
notstandsgesetz erlassen worden
das ist der kanzlerin ermöglicht einen
koalitionspartner ihrer wahl zu zwingen
mit gewalt deswegen hat sich martin
schulz mit seinen letzten getreuen hier
im willy brandt haus verschanzt und alle
türen abgeschlossen aber das wird ihm
nichts nutzen
ja richtig so obwohl die doch mal raus
die feigen verbessert wird wieder
gearbeitet
deutschland braucht eine regierung die
mussten ja jetzt reingehen der schulz
gräbt sich sonst einen fluchttunnel nach
würselen
ja aber so kann man das doch nicht
machen wieso denn nicht mein gott die
spd hat sich jetzt vier jahre von mutti
missbrauchen lassen da kommt so auf 4
mehr auch nicht mehr an
die sind fertig ausgelutscht durch
geritten schulz sagt ernsthaft wir
scheuen neuwahlen unverändert nicht
solltest du aber freundchen wie willst
du denn mit dem noch wahlkampf machen
ich zitiere berühmte schulz setzte aus
seinem letzten wahlkampf ich habe ja
nicht den hauch einer chance und
natürlich ich habe keine lust ich will
nach hause
an diesem mann klebt doch der faulige
geruch der niederlage der muss froh sein
wenn die märklin überhaupt noch haben
will
ja aber was will denn der rest der spd
das wissen die doch selber nicht
ralf stegner will weder groko noch
neuwahlen
olaf scholz wer gern halben meter größer
und und die basis ist offensichtlich
verrückt geworden als ich präferiere das
wäre natürlich eine spd-geführte
minderheitsregierung
ja natürlich
[Musik]
genau und danach gewinnt der erste fc
köln die champions league um den nicht
ich würde das präparieren
den kannst du nicht mehr helfen ach guck
mal
jetzt holen die den schulz da draußen
und bringdienst kanzler
die hörzu und an deutschland denken
junge wie romantischen ingo kuss meine
damen und herren
die wand